voilà ces derniers cartons
ok bah je vais descendre oui
mach quoi vous êtes en chine
non je suis témoin de jeu vous avez deux
minutes en accordéon ah non moi je n'ai
mis à déménager j'ai vraiment pas le
temps mais oui je suis un génie le fait
que j'apparais d'un coup comme ça c'est
un indice en fait vous êtes connus comme
génie je vais dire c'est quoi votre nom
serge d'accord et du contenu j'ai trois
voeux alors non je voudrais à combien de
voeux alors 0
mais al adha avec sa guitare aladin
c'est une lampe à huile et alors et
alors lampe à huile et qu'elle veut et
lampe de poche égal est ce que tu
préfères
est ce que tu préfères quoi je t'en fais
un facile pour commencer
est ce que tu préfères un tee shirt
rouge ou un tee shirt vert un tee shirt
rouge au hockey parce que c'est sous des
habits oui moi je suis gêné à la base un
n'est pas en train de jouer action
vérité avec ton petit cousin et si je
veux pas jouer
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah tu meurs ah
oui ça rigole pas un règlement règlement
c'est juste que tu me réveille je me
suis couché à 2h ans qui en plus tu
commences à pinailler
je te défonce alors est ce que tu
préfères un doigt au milieu du front ou
un bras mais au milieu du ventre
un bras au milieu du ventre ok
abracadabra ok bon est ce que tu
préfères entendre les pensées de tous
les gens que tu croises ou que tous les
gens que tu croises entendent dépenser
maintenant des pensées de tous les gens
que je croise au hockey connard connor
que narconon reconnaît un connard comme
un connard connor connard connard connor
connard connor connard konaré quoi c'est
évident ok est ce que tu préfères tu as
cassé la lente
non non je les répare et en fait oui tu
voudrais par itv
en tout cas c'est vraiment hyper sympa
d'être venus nous aider un essai dramane
on gagne mais on n'est pas amis toi et
moi j'avais juste besoin de supporter
mes cartons
alors est ce que tu préfères tu évanouir
quand tu répond à une question ou te
faire gifler quand tu peux une question
m'épanouir quand je réponds à une
question des sueurs ouais un peu mais à
chaque fois ça c'est très très chiant
est-ce que je peux changer ça non tu
peux pas changer nos pourquoi on avait
frappé alors parce que tu m'énerves
alors est-ce que tu préfet ce qui se
passe si je détruis la langue bassa du
tout bon à rien mais abracadabra
ça y est c'est fini ouais par contre tu
ferais attention il ya un faux contact
sur ta lampe de poche
pour assieds toi parce que tu vas
prendre cher toi bon alors est ce que tu
préfères tu abonnés à la chaîne youtube
aimer la page facebook ou suivent le
compte twitter ou salive et du gravier
pendant un an avant les sommets est ce
que tu préfères l'école de la
pornographie batman contre superman ou
les chants de supporters ou laisser la
vidéo se termine et cliquez sur rien